I always struggle with this question in
part because I there's gonna sound so
cliched but I'm very forward marching
and that can be debilitating at times I
feel like I've blinders on that are just
looking towards the future and sometimes
that affects me because it prevents me
from reflecting well on mistakes but the
first that comes to mind and this was
not just a mistake it was maybe a
collection of what I perceived at the
time to be disasters was in college
undergrad when I had a huge dispute with
my thesis advisor I also felt like I was
being funneled into one of two
industries management consulting or
Investment Banking this is at Princeton
very few industries come to recruit
there and as a competitor I was
compelled I felt compelled just as I had
in school to try to get a etc to compete
for the McKinsey's and Goldman Sachs of
the world and I remember getting through
one round of interviews and just
thinking to myself I don't want to do
either of these things but everyone else
wants them therefore perhaps I should
want them too and that's a big big
warning signal that's a red flag took me
a while to identify that and with the
help of an entrepreneurship high tech
entrepreneurship teacher named Ed Xiao
Zi SCH a you incredible man but due to
the issues with my thesis I wasn't going
to finish it on time for a host of
reasons if people want to learn more
about that they can look up some
thoughts on suicide pretty intense and
morbid title or some practical thoughts
on suicide and my name and it should pop
right up but I went into a deep
depression after leaving Princeton for a
year so I decided to take a year off to
do two things to work on the thesis and
I was told very surprisingly by my
adviser it better be the best thesis
I've ever seen in effect I'm going to
give you a terrible terrible grade and
there's a lot of background there I
won't bore people with right now but I
felt like I was completely trapped in a
corner with that and
on the positive side I decided to test
working at companies of different sizes
so I worked at Berlitz for a period of
time helping to redesign some of their
Japanese instruction curriculum and I
also worked at a political asylum
research firm and that was very small
two or three people and I learned a lot
so where it led me was realizing I
didn't want to work in a company of say
ten thousand people or many thousands of
people which Berlitz was and I was
working remotely so I also realized
there was a social component that was
really important to me I liked to work
around people even if my team were
remote I wanted to be surrounded by
people and ended up working at home by
myself a lot and it was mentally
destructive the political asylum
research was fantastic because it really
put my issues at that time into
perspective because I was dealing with
people who were let's just say
homosexuals in a country where they were
going to be killed or had been
threatened with death where family
members had been killed or for religious
differences and they were filing for
asylum in the United States to try to
escape this type of persecution and my
job was to find experts who could be
witnesses and determined what they would
call the meritorious nature of these
cases and brutal work because there were
instances where their case was valid but
for a host of technicalities or process
reasons in the u.s. system of addressing
such things we couldn't help them and so
literally be like sorry you have to go
back to this country where you're
probably going to be killed or your
family's going to be killed your kids
are going to be attacked and those very
very brutal but very helpful at the same
time for putting my first tool problems
should we say into perspective which are
no less serious in many respects I
should point out I don't fetishize that
like a lot of people and the the very
process of having to contend with these
existential issues seeing my classmates
graduate graduate a year before me
because I went back to school I felt
completely alone during this period of
year and it reinforced a few things for
me like the importance of exercise so
that is when I focused on boxing I went
to this gym in Trenton I don't know if
I've talked about this stuff before I
went to a gym in Trenton I was the only
white guy there almost everyone is on
work release and I remember the first
workout they're like oh see how you move
they put me in the ring with this guy
who is a heavyweight and immediately
broke my nose and just bled everywhere
and people laughed initially and then
they were like Jesus this is this this
guy's bleeding all over the ring and
pulled me out and I kept training there
and that from that point on they were
fine with me but the exercise is what
kept me sane and that's when I did the
the kickboxing training and so on that
led to the Nationals later in 1999
that's when that was and that story
ended up in the 4-hour workweek so a lot
of these existential issues led me to
make decisions then this is leading to a
better thing coming back into school and
continuing to study under edge shell and
look at entrepreneurship and starting my
own thing as the path as opposed to
having forged ahead perhaps looking back
on it trying to spin it with some silver
lining if my if I hadn't had the issues
in college that I did that led me to
drop out and have all of that pain
there's a very non-trivial chance let's
just call it 60 70 percent chance that I
would have ended up at McKinsey or
Goldman Sachs nothing wrong with those
things there are some people who are
just hard wired to succeed in those
environments and they're perfect fit but
you can't take an undergraduate body of
5,000 people and just divvy it up into
two industries and expect everyone to be
a good fit I wasn't but there's a very
good chance I would have ended up in one
of those career paths and I think I
would have been miserable I think
therefore would not have been terribly
good at it and I would have had ended up
changing direction five 10 20 years
later and instead the universe kicked me
in the nuts and uppercutted me in the
[ __ ] teeth and that was a good thing
so in the end of six months I figured
out what could have taken me 10 to 15
years
figure out so thanks for that universe I
don't need too many of those in my life
but at the time that was a good course
correction if you enjoyed this video I
have more to share all of the tools
tactics cool things that I'm finding
five bullet Friday it is an exclusive
newsletter it's completely free I sent
it out every Friday just has five bullet
points with the coolest most useful
things that I found or I'm revisiting
that week and you can find it by
clicking here takes about five minutes
to read super short very actionable 502
Friday also found at 4-hour workweek
comm board slash Friday